we all want to be happy but the majority
of us have no idea what to do see the
Japanese have a concept called ikigai
which roughly translates into a reason
for being you need to have a purpose for
being here but this is easier said than
done because there are four components
that you need to check off in order to
achieve ikigai the first component is
that it needs to be something that you
love we all have things that make us
feel good things that make us stop
thinking for short periods of time to
just be present and aware of what's
happening right now in front of us the
more technical people will call this
Flow State but the majority of us call
it love that's why so many of us enjoy
the Arts drawing dancing singing reading
because it takes us into the state of
bliss where we feel good and are focused
on the task in front of us that's why
some of us fall in love with one another
because being with that person allows us
to forget about all the other problems
in our lives at least momentarily I
don't need to get into too much detail
about this component because we know in
our gut when we truly love to do
something it's a feeling that we humans
all share follow us for more helpful
tips